on va voir les étiquettes effectivement
de cette équipe gouvernementale on
compte h ministres venus des r DLR ou de
l'UMP on a simplifié h ministres qui
venaient de la droite h étaient des
marcheurs de la première heure SEP
ministres ou secrétaire d'État viennent
d rendre la gauche ce qui fait dire
qu'il y a donc un léger rééquilibrage
même si les principaux portefeuilles
ceux qui sont régaliens ils sont à
droite pour ce qui est des alliés de la
majorité on continue on compte quatre
modem trois horizon un ministre issu du
par radical et enfin quatre ministres
qui viennent de la société civile voilà
l'équilibre politique de ce gouvernement
on va évidemment parler du MoDem dans
quelques instants mais est-ce que c'est
un gouvernement qui a été rééquilibré on
a parlé d'une première salle de
gouvernement qui était très à droite
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a un équilibre
politique gouvernemental pour vous
Benjamin modérément c'est-à-dire que sur
le papier oui en effet si on fait le
décomte il y a je dirit une forme de
permanence dans la répartion des postes
en revanche les plus importants ça a été
évoqué mais sont quand même tenus plutôt
par des personnalités venant de la
droite voire venant de la Sarkozy et
forcément si on pense un petit peu
équilibre au sein de la majorité il
n'est pas certain que la gauche de la
majorité est vraiment à se féliciter
malgré le la rentrée de Nicole Boué qui
est déjà
chuté politiquement et de l'autre côté
le modem et horizon ne sont guerre plus
contents que la veille c'est-à-dire que
on connaît évidemment on reviendra sans
doute sur la crise avec François baayrou
horizon ne voit pas non plus son poids
fondamentalement renforcé donc là cor on
a un gouvernement mais ce gouvernement
il ne facilitera pas les relations au
sein de la majorité Stéphane moi moi
j'ai envie de vous dire que les
éthquette ça compte plus tellement en
fait je crois que ça a pas grand sens ça
ça envoie pas un signal sur la ligne
politique aucun franchement enfin moi à
mon avis aucun alors évidemment on peut
on peut regarder dans le détail et
cetera mais je pense que ça compte pour
personne c'est pas le vrai sujet je
pense que le rééquilibrage il se fait
plutôt du côté des territoires on a ça y
est on a enfin des des ministres au sud
de la Loire la vérité ah mais on va y
venir rassurez-vous et puis et la vérité
c'est qu'en fait enfin moi moi je un
mois pour qu'on nous r sorte le même
gouvernement ça n'a aucun sens quoi je
veux dire c'est c'est un tour c'est un
gouvernement qui parle on va revenir sur
la la territorialisation ça mais est-ce
que dans les 35 ministres qu'on connaît
maintenant c'est un gouvernement qui
parle au français pour vous euh alors
est-ce que c'est un gouvernement qui
parle au français je suis désolé de vous
le dire mais je pense que les précédents
gouvernements parlaient pas au français
en fait c'est-à-dire que vous aviez si
on parle si on parle de la perception de
de nos dirigeants par le grand public la
c'est que les gens connaissent en gros
en grosso modo on pe on peut compter le
nombre de mines qui sont identifiés par
par les Français les françaises sur les
ça se compte sur les doigs d'une main
quoi bon bah en même temps là c'est un
peu tout ça pour ça ah mais c'est pas un
peu c'est complètement tout ça pour ça
en fait à l'arrivée on se dit bah
finalement il s'agissait de changer de
Premier ministre mais pourquoi attendre
30 jours s'il s'agissait juste de
changer de Premier ministre pour faire
durer un suspense comme ça merveilleux
au bout duquel finalement on reprend
quasiment on reprend quasiment tous les
mêmes on fait quelques entrées à la
marge à part deux ou trois virgules je
veux dire quels sont les quels sont les
quels sont les changements moi je vois
pas et d'ailleurs c'est votre édito ce
matin dans West France vous écrivez tout
ça pour ça à la Une du journal ce matin
oui sans l'avoir
lu Quentin il il a décortiqué pour va
vous en parler dans quelques instants
Benjamin est-ce que c'est vrai qu'on on
a parlé de l'effet waou quand gabrielal
est arrivé là son son premier
gouvernement estce est-ce qu'il y a un
fait gouvernement àal non et c'est
contre c'est totalement contreproductif
parce que on peut interroger je dirais
la nomination de Gabriel àal il y a un
intérêt qui en effet essayer d'avoir un
souffle pour les européennes s Clive au
sein de la majorité parce qu'en effet la
gauche est sousreésentée le modem est
pas content donc on noublit ses
capacités à légiférer fort bien mais on
l'oublit quand même pour quelque chose
il s'agit de lancer le souffle quand le
souffle vous déjà vous le fragilisez en
prévoyant un discours politique général
extrêmement lointain après la nomination
et donc en pleine crise qui était pas
tout à fait improbable mais en tout cas
qui aurait pu être autre quoi qu'il
arrive au au cent du monde agricole bah
déjà vous coupez le souffle lorsque vous
mettez un mois c'était la limite hein il
faut voir que les ministres qui étaient
les ministres qui étaient un peu en
suspens notamment les ministres délégués
ils avaient un mois pour revenir au
Parlement donc on pouvait pas attendre
plus sinon ben soit on faisait des
législatives partielles pour ceux qui
auraient dû démissionner soit il
revenaient au Parlement et ensuite bah
il fallait remettre leur suppléents et
on avait des suppléant qui est poiroté
encore pendant un mois donc ça
fragilisait un peu plus la majorité donc
c'était vraiment la limite de la limite
pour au bout du compte renommer à peu
près les mêmes ministres je suis
d'accord souvent des ministres qui sont
très peu connus et donc faire un jeu de
chaise musicale qui n'intéresse pas
vraiment les Français c'est
contreproductif d'autant que l'objectif
qu'on peut discuter d'avoir un
gouvernement resserré objectif de
communication impliquer qu'on fasse
passer un peu sous le Boissau cette de
cette deuxème salve de nomination
c'était aussi l'objectif or là en
occurrence le fait que ça a duré des
jours et des jours et qu'on en a quand
même beaucoup parlé et qu'in Finet il
est pas certain que l'effet gouvernement
resserré s'il a eu un jour une chance de
marquer l'opinion bah soit vraiment
enregistré Stéphane oui ben d'autant
plus qu'il est moins resseré que prévu
quoi c'està-dire que tout le monde n
disait il y aura ce sera 30 maxi 30 maxi
ils sont 35 à l'arrivée encore t Premier
ministre c'est mieux que c'est mieux que
par le passé enfin bon c'est pas c'est
pas
fouou non plus hein donc voilà et
effectivement c'est une moi je pense que
c'est une c'est une deuxième vague qui
aurait dû passer inaperçu qui aurait pu
passer inaperçu mais c'était sans
compter sur la surprise du chef François
Beyou qui sort du chapeau au dernier
moment et et le le je je trouve que le
le en terme d'image et de comm le le
l'effet est totalement raté quoi c'est
désastreux c'est c'est désastreux
pourquoi avoir attendu si longtemps pour
ça et et et pourquoi avoir laissé durer
le suspense jusqu'à créer une crise
interne à la majorité enfin alors est-ce
qu'il y a vraiment une crise interne
parce que on a entendu on a entendu la
colère de François beou ces derniers
temps mais il y a quatre ministres modem
dans ce gouvernement un ministre de
plein exercice Marc fen quatre deux
ministres délégués une secrétaire d'État
est-ce que ce qui est la même chose que
dans le dernier gouvernement B est-ce
que du coup la crise elle est pas plutôt
à l'intérieur du MoDem entre ce que dit
François baayrou et finalement ce que
fait le reste troup ça a été très bien
résumé par jean-lu bourlange qui a fait
un communiqué hier qui pris la parole en
disant mais c'est insensé politiquement
ça n'a pas de sens et il a raison
c'est-à-dire vous pouvez pas dire
Jean-Luc Mourlan je dit à juste titre il
aurait on aurait pu dire nous soutenons
ce ce gouvernement sans y participer on
a pas de ministre et là le choix qui est
fait c'est nous participons on y est
mais on le soutient pas ça n'a c'est
insensé ça n'a pas de sens et quand vous
voyez le coup de sang parce que c'est un
coup de sang de François baayrou
mercredi soir la la la question qu'on se
pose immédiatement c'est ben jusqu'où
est qui jusqu'où ça va aller
c'est-à-dire est-ce que le modem va
sortir de la majorité présidentielle et
là il y avait quand même un vrai très
très très très gros enjeux parce qu'un
modem qui sort de la majorité
présidentielle c'est un modem qui qui
aurait été capable de mettre à à à
l'œuvre un certain nombre de menaces qui
avait été proféré depuis un mois en
disant ben nous allons puisque c'est
comme ça nous allons monter notre propre
liste aux Européennes et des européennes
avec une liste modemme indépendante
c'est plus du tout la même élection et
c'est plus du tout la même suite de
l'histoire parce que les ces européennes
au-delà de l'enjeu européen lui-même il
y a elle conditionne aussi toute la
dynamique et toute la suite pour les 3
années qui restent jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 donc donc voilà
et le le rétropédalage de François
baayrou dès le
lendemain matin vient et là pour
contrebalancer son son coup de s il
s'est fait rattraper il s'est fait
rattraper par la patrouille ses propres
troupes lui disent bah tu aurais pu nous
consulter tu es allé trop loin on n pas
sur France Info hier vous pensez qu'il a
il a rétropédalé parce qu'il osait plus
aller aussi loin ces critique c'est ça
il parlait plus d'humiliation alors il
reste il reste critique mais il il était
venu il est venu sur le plateau pour
dire que le modem restait était dans la
majorité présidentielle je pense que
c'était une précision qui s'imposait il
fallait la faire vite et il l'a faite et
je pense qu'il politique était
uniquement sur l'éducation nationale il
est il était très précis c'était qu'en
fait il y avait une différence de vision
sur ce qu'il fallait faire à l'éducation
nationale ça resté ça en fait le il est
all il est allé plus loin moi je pense
que c'est l'expression d'une très grosse
déception mais qui couvre depuis au
moins 2 ans le le comment dire le il y a
une grande déception de François baayrou
par rapport par rapport au par rapport
au pouvoir en 2022 vous avez un
président de la République qui s'est
coupé d'un certain nombre de de ses
interlocuteurs habituels de ses bases le
le l'entourage ce qu'on appelle
l'entourage du président c'est
considérablement rétréci en 2022 et
François Baayou ou Édouard Philippe n'en
font plus partie et François baayrou ça
il le vide très très mal et et je pense
que le le son coup de sang encore une
fois j'insiste de mercredi il est aussi
directement lié à à son niveau de
déception ouais mais est-ce que là il a
pas nui à son parti est-ce qu'il rend
pas illisible la position du MoDem entre
lui qui critique la ligne politique et
finalement quatre ministres qui sont au
gouvernement bah c'est toute la
difficulté si vous voulez la l'une des
questions et mais en fait qui est pas si
nouvelle c'est est-ce que François
Baayou c'est le modem et est-ce que le
modem c'est François Baayou dès la
précédente législature il y avait des
tensions entre le groupe et le président
du parti aujourd'hui bah ces tensions
arrivent à maturité mais elles sont pas
si nouvelles parce que François baayrou
sur ce sujet-l ne consulte pas certes
Emmanuel Macron ne le consulte pas mais
lui-même ne consulte pas ses troupes et
donc ce faisant la force de François
baayerou ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il
pèse dans la majorité c'est pas
seulement lié à sa personnalité c'est
surtout lié à ses 51 députés si jamais
ces 51 députés deain ne le suivait pas
n'était pas apte éventuellement à
incarner je dirais une forme de rupture
avec lui à ce moment-là il pèse beaucoup
moins donc arver à faire l'unité au sein
de son groupe pour peser au sein de
cette majorité c'est un point qui est un
point névralgique après il y a une
question qui se pose à François Baayou
mais qui se pose à d'autres c'est à
quand assumer une forme de rupture pour
être à la fois dans la majorité mais ne
pas apparaître comme étant comptable du
bilan de chef de l'État et tout bêtement
ne pas forcément en assumer l'héritage
et là on a une stratégie un peu
sarkoosienne si vous voulez c'est-à-dire
comment incarner la rupture dans le
changement et en la matière François
baayerou incarne en disant ce qu'il a
dit ça est-ce que c'est pas trop tôt
est-ce que c'est pas fracturer déjà une
majorité bien malade est-ce que ce n'est
pas apparaître comme étant un frantireur
et prendre le risque de partir seul
alors que pour l'instant il a un il a
une organisation il a un parti qui
permet potentiellement d'envisager une
candidature c'est ça la question qui a
été posée ces derniers jours parmi les
questions posées il y a celle de la
répartition territorial on est dans le
club des territoires on va évidemment
parler on a beaucoup entendu cette
critique Quentin est-ce que c'est un
gouvernement parisien mais c'est vrai
qu'en plus vous en parliez Stéphan
c'était l'un des reproches adressés à la
première vague de nomination notamment
par François baayrou pour dénoncer
l'absence de tout ministre issu d'un
département au sud de la Loire c'est
réparé a priori avec les nominations
d'hier Nico Boubé vient de Toulouse
comme Dominique fort sabrina
agrtioubach est identifié comme élu
marseillaise Marina Ferrari que l'on
découvre qui est une nouvelle ministre
elle rentre au numérique elle vient de
savoir Thomas casazenav au budget est
élu à Bordeaux toutes les régions
métropolitaines sont représentées à
l'exception de la Corse Oriane en
revanche on ne compte pas de ministres
venue d'une collectivité d'outre m ouais
on parla évidemment de cette répartition
territoriale Stéphan elle a une
importance on voyait d'ailleurs ce matin
dans la PQR et ces derniers jours chaque
titre de presse régionale attendait de
savoir s'il allait avoir un ministre ça
parle ça au français chaque ministre
chaque Français pardon voudrait avoir un
ministre de sa région c'est c'était
aussi un enjeu pour ce gouvernement àal
ou pas alors je sais pas si chaque
Français ou chaque française a envie
d'avoir un ministre de sa région je suis
pas je suis pas persuadé par contre oui
c'est un enjeu pour le gouvernement Atal
et en fait je pense qu'il faut pas se
Tromp d'objet c'est-à-dire que ce
gouvernement quand on dit ce
gouvernement est trop parisien c'est pas
le fait que ses membres soient euh très
majoritairement issu de Paris ou de la
de l'île- de- France ce qui est ce qui
est ce qui est sous-jacent dans cette
critique c'est le parisianisme des gens
qui sont au pouvoir c'est une petite
nuance en fait parce que vous pouvez
très bien être venir de la province et
être très parisien dans enfin voilà très
empreintte parisianisme dans dans votre
façon de penser d'exercer le le pouvoir
de voir les choses et de voir la France
et le rééquilibrage il était il était le
rééquilibrage nécessaire il était il
était là donc quand vous avez quand vous
avez dans cette seconde vague euh le le
retour plutôt que l'entrée le retour au
gouvernement d'un certain nombre de
ministres délégués et quelques
secrétaires d'État qui effectivement ont
un ancrage local euh oui c'est plutôt de
nature à à rassurer par rapport à cette
problématique il y a c'est aussi c'est
aussi la question de l'exercice réel
d'un mandat c'està que l'ancrage le le
le fait de pas être complètement
déconnecté il est lié aussi au fait que
vous avez des ministres qui euh qui qui
ont fait autre chose ou qui font autre
chose en parallèle de de leur activité
euh euh gouvernementale c'est aussi
plutôt ça c'est-à-dire que euh là on
revient à un autre sujet qui est ancien
qui est celui du non cumule des mandats
et cetera mais on a aussi une
génération de d'hommes et de femmes
politiques qui qui a pas qui a pas
pratiqué de qui n'a pas eu de mandat
d'élus local et ça moi je pense que
quand vous arrivez au top du top c'est
c'est ça manque je pense que c'est c'est
une expérience qui est pour pour sentir
en fait les affaires de de la France et
le rapport au territoire euh
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
qui est qui est plus que très utile
c'est indispensable ou vraiment oui
c'est aussi une affaire de
stratification sociale on va pas non
plus se mentir hein c'est un
gouvernement c'était c'est encore un
gouvernement très parisien surtout des
arrondissements très centraux de Paris
si je suis un peu caricatural et de
l'autre côté et bien il y a un sujet
également et je rejoins ce qui a été dit
en fait de cursous sonorum politique la
question c'est comment est-ce que vous
accédez au mandat politique est-ce que
vous y accédez après avoir fait les NA
et cetera est-ce que vous y accédez
parce que vous avez fait votre curs
sonorum dans un parti ou à travers un
curs sonorum également partisan mais
dans les collectivités territoriales
vous avez roulé votre boss pendant 20
ans dans les communes dans les
départements dans les régions puis un
jour vous êtes député puis ensuite
ministre et évidemment ça conditionne
une pratique politique cette pratique
politique et les réseaux qui sont les
votres au niveau local ben enrichissent
quelque peu votre expérience il faut une
diversité malgré tous des profils cette
diversité elle existe de moins en moins
et ce qui fait également que ça compte
moins pour l'exécutif pour ce quoi par
parce que nager quand vous aviez d'un
côté le Parti socialiste ou de l'autre
LR ou avant le RPR ludf bah il fallait
faire plaisir à vos grandes fédérations
et donc l'équilibrage territorial
c'était également un équilibrage
partisan vous pouviez pas négliger la
féd des bouches du rô la fédé du Nord il
fallait donner des gages or Emmanuel
Macron n'a pas ce problème parce que Ben
Renaissance n'est pas un parti au sens
ancien du terme mais c'est également ça
avait également ses avantages et ses
avantages il lui manquent ça quand même
mais est-ce que est-ce que du coup il
donne pas dégage parce que le macronisme
il est très francilien est-ce que le
cœur de son électorat c'est pas un
électorat francilien finalement alors
oui et non eu il donne des gages en
effet à l'électorat francilien mais son
électorat si vous regardez un peu sa
stratification elle est d'abord sociale
plus vous montez dans l'échelle de
revenu plus vous avez de chance de voter
Macron plus vous descendez moins vous
avez de chance de voter Macron et elle
est également en terme d'âge hein avec
notamment une part assez importante de
l'électorat retraité et c'est là que en
effet il y a quand même un rôle dans
l'équilibrage territorial tout bêtement
parce que Ben ce qui va compter
notamment à travers l'accès à la presse
quotidienne régionale à ancrage dans les
élections locales et cetera d'un
électorat notamment retraité qui est
votant aux élections locales qui s'y
intéresse à cette vie politique locale
et ben va faire que avoir un ministre du
coin ça peut quand même compter ça peut
quand même permettre en vue des
européennes de charer une partie de cet
électorat ou de lui donner le sentiment
qu'il est représenté qu'il est considéré
donc c'est pas non plus tout à fait
neutre politiquement l'avoir négligé le
négliger même si un petit rééquilibrage
et probablement pas de bonne stratégie
ouais mais est-ce qu'il y a un risque du
coup d'envoyer un signal que Emmanuel
Macron et Gabriel Atal ne s'intéresse
pas au territoire même si Gabriel Atal
hier soir sur France 2 il a bien pris
soin de dire qu'il y avait des ministres
qui représentaient différentes régions
qu'il y avait des élus de montagne qui
avait des élus ruraux et queil y avait
beaucoup d'élus locaux dans son
gouvernement mais quand même est-ce que
le signale le risque il est pas là mais
c'est surtout que on a on a un Premier
ministre qui qui qui depuis qu'il est
nommé en fait sol le territoire en long
en large et en travers il était dans le
Pas de Calais hier et cetera enfin il
multiplie les déplacements il va il va
au contact et il le fait plutôt pas mal
mais oui oui il y a un enjeu c'est
essayer de créer une une proximité alors
quels sont les bons moyens pour créer
cette ce ce lien ce contact
euh c'est compliqué c'est c'est c'est
c'est une question qui ENF il est
difficile de répondre efficacement à
cette question est-ce que aller faire du
terrain suffit moi je suis pas persuadé
mais comme je suis pas persuadé non plus
qu'il suffise d'avoir des des ministre
du cru pour automatiquement générer un
rapport de proximité un attachement je
pense que c'est effectivement je suis
d'accord avec Benjamin c'est c'est oui
ça ça peut ça ça peut ça peut jouer mais
il y a pas de recette miracle je pense
ça suffit pas et les choses vont c'est
quelque chose qui va se qui ne peut se
développer que dans le temps et par de
l'action et des preuves concrète de
cette de cette de la construction de
cette relation ça se décrète pas un mot
mais en effet le temps est nécessaire
prenons un exemple historique Jacques
Chirac ja shirac il est très parisien
d'ailleurs il est maire de Paris et il
n'incarne pas vraiment la province
profonde à l'origine mais lorsque vous a
passé des années et des années dans la
vie politique lorsque vous avez
développé votre image et cetera vous
finissez par pouvoir incarner quelque
chose le problème actuellement du
personnel politique de manière générale
majorité et opposition c'est qu'on a un
personnel politique d'étoiles filantes
de gens qui n'ont pas le temps de
construire une relation avec un endroit
avec une circonscription avec un
territoire et d'incarner quelque chose
de manière structurelle dans l'opinion
et qui donc sont renvoyéés à leurs
origines sociales originelles entre
guillemets et ça évidemment ben c'est
marquant ouais enfin puis juste un mot
mais c'est on parlait du cumu du nom
cumulé bandat mais je vous rappelle que
je girirac il s'était inventé une double
vie en corise aussi hein donc euh il
était pas que mer de Paris donc parmi
vos parmi vos autres décomptes Quentin
il y a évidemment le décompte du nombre
de parlementaires bon il y a pas
vraiment de match non c'est vrai
effectivement on compte 19 députés dans
cette nouvelle version du gouvernement
sur 35 he je vous le rappelle ministre
secrétaire d'État c'est beaucoup 19 et
un seul sénateur Sébastien Lecornu élu
dans l'heure en 2000 20 mais qui n'a
jamais siégé à la Haute Assemblée car
ministre depuis son élection alors cela
signe effectivement l'échec de tentative
de débauchage individuel on avait lu
dans la presse qu' avait des noms de
personnalité beaucoup de centristes voir
même peut-être des LR qui circulait pour
rentrer au gouvernement finalement on
n'en voit pas depuis hier alors est-ce
qu'il y en a vraiment eu de la part de
l'Élysée ou est-ce que et bien c'est la
majorité sénatoriale de la droite et du
centre qui a résisté à ces appels de
l'exécutif ça on sera dans les
prochaines heures prochains jours
Benjamin on peut y voir un un signe
d'unité de la majorité sénatoriale qui
n'a pas cédé au sirène gouvernemental
alors oui en effet alors je dirais si on
regarde ça d'un point de vue général
c'est relativement logique parce que le
groupe euh Renaissance ici est très
limité en terme de nombre et donc les
ressources étaient pas là mais il y
avait une volonté malgré tout d'ouvrir
la question ensuite elle est double
est-ce que aujourd'hui pour des
centristes ou deslr il est tout à fait
opportun de rentrer dans ce gouvernement
c'est pas tout à fait évident hein vous
rentrez quand même dans quelque chose
dont vous voyez pas forcément ce que ça
deviendra à court terme et de l'autre
côté est-ce que pour Emmanuel Macron et
pour Gabriel Atal faire venir des
sénateurs c'est obtenir le soutien du
Sénat c'est pas tout à fait évident non
plus vous a pas échappé que la
nomination de rachti navait pas vraiment
plusu ici et que donc à partir de là
aujourd'hui l'idée qu'on pourrait
s'appuyer sur le Sénat contre une
assemblée récal citrante bah est
probablement une idée qui si ce n'est a
vécu en tout cas n'est plus aussi
pertinente ouais ce ce cette deuxième
vague elle acte l'échec de l'élarg de la
majorité Stéphane alors moi j'ai j'ai
une autre j'ai une autre interprétation
possible je dis pas que c'est ce qui
s'est passé mais je je vais vous
proposer quelque chose peut-être je me
trompe mais je pense que c'est un
problème de méthode je vous explique en
fait le pour composer cette deuxième
vague vous avez le comment l'Élisée
Matignon ils se sont tournés vers un
certain nombre de pontes de de de la
majorité présidentielle en leur disant
mais qui tu verrais toi dans tel ou tel
poste faites-nous remonter des noms
voilà et chacun avait pour mission
d'envoyer deux noms et donc ils ont fait
leur liste de cours
donc ils ont mis oh ben moi je verrai
bien tarteempion tarte me à tel ou tel
poste et voilà et puis bah le problème
de de la politique c'est que c'est que
c'est on affaire à des gens très
bavardes donc il y en a plein qui ont
causé et en disant ah bah oui un tel ou
une telle va rentrer au gouvernement
simplement parce que c'est les noms
qu'il avait il ou elle avait proposé et
ça devient une espèce de de de vérité on
a eu plein de Fues partout qui disaent
il va y avoir un tel machin est présenti
alors est-ce est-ce que c'est des gens
qui ont été effectivement approchés et
qui ont résisté et qui ont refusé dans
la liste dans le total peut-être mais je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup estce que c'est
des gens qui ont jamais été
contactéil qui découvre leur propre nom
dans la et voilà comment vous créer un
écran de fumé mais je pense qu'ils ont
pas fait exprès en fait c'est
juste après encore une fois peutêre que
TR non mais est-ce que ça envoit aussi
quand même pas pas de sénateur alors y a
l'exception Sébastien lecorn mais qui
n'a jamais siégé au Sénat mais qui qui
est élu sénateur est-ce que ça envoit
aussi le le signal que finalement
l'exécutif va très peu tenir compte du
Parlement bah la priorité est pas de
légiférer hein on en a déjà parlé mais
si vous considérez que la le présent
gouvernement ne vous es guerre à
solidifier votre majorité et encore
moins à l'élargir parce que évidemment
certains LR ont été nommés je pense
notamment à Rach Dati c'est pas
forcément quelque chose qui va permettre
de faire plaisir à Bruno rotillot et
Eric Coti donc mais on va pas gagner du
soutien alr si vous voulez donc
légiférer n'apparaît pas comme étant la
priorité donc en effet si légiféré n'est
pas la priorité le soutien du Sénat ne
l'est pas non plus et l'équilibre
délicat au sein du gouvernement déjà que
si vous devez arbitrer entre horizon
modem gauche de la majorité et cetera
plus les questions de parité et cetera
le facteur on introduit le Sénat dans le
jeu devient un facteur assez secondaire
au vu des tensions sur la nomination
même du gouvernement après ce qui est
relativement incohérent c'est que si
vous renoncez à légiférer bah vous
décidez de passer essentiellement par
voie de décret et de faire se mouvoir
vos administrations quand vous avvez un
gouvernement resserré avec des cabinets
ministériels resserrés et ben là il y a
une forme d'incohérence et on verra si
votre théorie se confirme Stéphane c'est
vendredi c'est ve de weekend on vous
emmène découvrir notre patrimoine et
notre tradition et jeenathan du Pr nous
emmène à dunkerer qu'ù va se dérouler le
traditionnel carnaval il a suivi les
préparatifs de cet événement avec des
fidèles du carnaval qui ne le manquerait
pour rien au
monde derrière le calme des rues
d'unquerque bouillonne c'est bientôt le
carnaval cette grande fête populaire qui
perdure depuis le 17e siècle avec ses
règles ses codes chers au dunkererquis
comme Domi Pedro et Franck ces vrais
carnavaleux porteront leur clich ces
costumes uniques qui ressemblent à des
œuvres d'art comme cette
réinterprétation du professeur Tournesol
de Tintin je vous présente Pedro
tournalcool donc le chapeau fait maison
la perruque fait maison le reste par une
couturière les gants les accessoires bah
c'est surtout moi qui m occupe outre son
chapeau orné de fleurs Domi 60 ans de
carnaval à son actif Harbor toutes
sortes de badges en référence à son
groupe de copines du carnaval les
cochonnes la bah là je cherche
jeun héritier mais ça fait 30 ans j'ai
toujours pas trouvé ces panoplies
déjanté ces trois compares se les
porteront lors des bandes le nom donné
aux différents défilés du carnaval de
dkererque et pour les costumes la règle
c'est que chacun fait ce qui lui plaît
faire ce qu'on veut au carnaval le
costume peut avoir un sens très
particulier chacun possède le sien
d'autres comme moi de temps en temps
j'aime changer parce que voilà je c'est
la liberté aussi autre incontournable
chez eux Domi et Pedro feront chapelle
autrement dit ils ouvriront leurs portes
au carnavaleux désirant de faire une
halte pour bien boire et bien manger
bière et autres diabolo flamand
côtoiront des moules à la nisette et des
harant au barbec même si c'est Pedro qui
s'occupe beaucoup de choses moi ça me
stresse quand même mais une fois que
tout le monde est là on est tellement
[Musique]
heureux Michel et Céline trépig
d'impatience aussi il forme l'un des
duos les plus en vu du carnaval lui est
tambourg major depuis 37 ans le maître
de cérémonie qui décide de tout et donne
le tempo à la bande le r c'est lui qui
donne le départ et c'est lui qui gère
les musiciens on se parle pas parce avec
le bruit et vu qu'il est plus Loir voà
donc c'est par SIG avec son costume sa
bEACe mais aussi son tonneau bien rempli
Céline sa cantinière sera les yeux et
les oreilles de Michel dans la bande il
peut pas être partout donc justement on
va l'épauler on va permettre de regarder
un petit peu s'il a pas des obstacles
sur sur sa route on donne à voir c'est
un poste qui est très prisé parce que
forcément c'est une fierté un odeur
àkererque vous avez vu pour le continire
qui est sérieure on lâche prise c'est ça
le carnaval de toute façon et après ben
on se fait des gros câlins voilà
l'événement fait battre le cœur des
derquis autant que celui de ses élus
l'un des temps forts est le jet de
quelques 3000 arant à la foule depuis le
balcon de l'hôtel de ville
80000 personnes sous les fenêtres de la
mairie un moment que marjorieois ne
rateraiit sous aucun prétexte autour de
ça en fait ce sont tout toutes les
générations toutes les classes sociales
qui se retrouvent il y a plus de
distinction les gens se prennent bras
dessus bras dessous et voilà c'est un
grand moment de convivialité de fierté
dunkerercoise bien plus qu'un joyeux
bazar le carnaval de dunkererque est une
tradition un patrimoine presque un monde
à lui seul et voilà pour ce carnaval de
duncar évidemment une tradition vous
irez lancer des har récup voilà on les
chop et on les mange ouais mais ça ça ce
sera évidemment à suivre tradition du
Nord Quentin regarde si elle a une de
nos quotidiens
[Musique]
régionaux et ce matin dans la presse
régionale on revient évidemment sur le
remanimement mais la liste des nouveaux
ministres et secrétaire d'État est
peut-être arrivé un peu trop tard vers
20h20 pour figurer dans toute la presse
régionale on note ces trois titres ce
matin Ouest France la Provence ou encore
le télégram je vous conseille l' ditito
Stéphane Vernet à la une qui parle de la
de la fin du faux départ et les Français
qui se disent peut-être ce matin tout ça
pour ça effectivement dans les pages
intérieures du télégram on revient
particulièrement sur l'exfiltration
d'améliie oua casterra au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale à sa place Nicole
Boubé un nouveau Paris risqué écrit le
journal breton on lit le scepticisme de
certains syndicats car ses convictions
apparaissent différentes de celles du
Premier ministre et avant l'annonce de
ce remanement Gabriel at était dans le
Pas de Calais voilà une deuxième visite
hier depuis sa nomination un mois la
voie du Nord raconte que les choses
avancent sur le front des inondations
avec les aides de l'État ce sont 510
millions d'euros mobilisés dont 320
millions au titre d'indemnisation
diverse a dit hier le Premier ministre
Gabriel Attal a déjà annoncé qu'il sera
de retour dans le pas decalais dans un
mois l'ancien président François
Hollande était face au lecteur de Nice
Matin et Var Matin une rencontre
organisée hier à Toulon dans le cadre de
sa fondation la France s'engage l'ancien
président a évoqué de nombreux sujets
raphaë gluxman est un bon candidat pour
les européennes mais ça ne suffira pas
pour la présidentielle Poutine et
l'Ukraine la Russie veut nous mettre à
l'épreuve enfin à lire dans le journal
ses regrets d'ancien président face au
frondeur pendant son quinquena allez ça
déjà une habitude du vendredi Quentin
après les marchés de Noël c'est le foot
maintenant voilà on termine avec un
petit mot pour les foti effectivement
Paris Normandie qui titre sur la bonne
performance du FC rouan face à Monaco
hier soir cela s'est encore joué au tir
au but comme régulièrement cette saison
effectivement ran qui affrontera
valencienne en car à la fin du mois de
février merci Quentin on regarde la de
West France Stéphan en plus de votre
excellente édito le gouvernement à
affiche en d'êre venu vous revenez quand
vous voulez Stéphane déjà on se retrouve
mardi merci beaucoup Stéphane Vern
merciin d'avoir été avec nous merci
Quentin merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
on vous souhaite un excellent weekend on
se retrouve
lundi